if you thought don't hug me I'm scared
was the most disturbing stuff on YouTube
think again is that right salad fingers
he'll become but damn I'm see seeing you
here
hello Internet welcome to film Theory
giving myself nightmares just to explain
a decades-old web series that's no
exaggeration I have been wrecked for a
week working on this thing but man what
a rewarding series it is to analyze so
as we prepare to hop right in let's
start with some context starting in 2004
and finally ending in 2013 with just 10
short episodes salad fingers was
successfully able to terrify a
generation making it one of the founding
fathers of online video terror I kid you
not I remember being in high school and
everyone daring each other to watch the
first episode of this the next day kids
would come back wracked I'll admit it
the build-up for how scary this thing
was was so strong that I actually didn't
watch it only just picking it up this
year to finally satisfy my curiosity
thinking hey I've grown up a bit this
shouldn't be nearly as scary as it was
when we were back in high school but I
was definitely wrong freakish imagery
gut-wrenching sound design and an
unsettling story all packaged and stiff
inhuman animations in the way only early
flash videos can animate it was and
still is the stuff of nightmares yet
despite its obvious scare factor what's
less obvious is the series plot with so
much of the story being told in
fractured pieces by unreliable
characters using abstract symbols what's
actually going on here is a bit of a
question the visuals and sound may be
the stuff of nightmares but the story
here is the stuff of theories which
means after all of these years of
avoiding watching it myself it's now my
turn to dare you to watch the Salad
Fingers series if you haven't yet and if
you think you can handle it by clicking
right here it's a little under an hour
and it's well worth it to not only
understand this theory but witness some
of the most influential early flash
animations online plus with Halloween
around the corner we'll give you some
spooky fun all right
right a toss some salad let's go now
when trying to analyze
something as abstract as Salad Fingers
we have to start with the most basic
questions and work from there
so where is this story set well we see
Salad Fingers roaming a mostly barren
wasteland filled with strange mutants
and burned-out houses leading many to
think that this is a post-apocalyptic
universe however based on context clues
we can get a lot more specific when
discussing his earlier life cell and
finger says she used to sing at all the
functions from Crocs LaHaye to
Cowdenbeath both of which are real-world
locations in the United Kingdom he
mentions Crocs Lee again this time
saying that he listened to it on the
radio in episode 8 if I'm in tally bed I
listen to crack Slee so we know that he
lives in the UK but we can also identify
the year in episode 6 present the
titular present that he received as a
toy horse that he refers to as I am
Horace Hoss collar Noah study says my
very own horace horsecollar meaning that
horace horsecollar is already something
in existence and indeed he is horace
horsecollar was the name of a cheerful
know-it-all cartoon character created by
walt disney back in 1929 as a partner to
Mickey Mouse in all of his adventures
basically he was like the earlier
version of goofy appearing in animations
between 1929 and 1942 but we can narrow
that range further as we hear Salad
Fingers sing both the songs somewhere
over the rainbow and we'll meet again at
various points throughout the series two
songs both released in 1939 and 1939 is
a crucial years as it falls right
between World War 1 and the start of
World War 2
throughout salad fingers are leafy green
hero talks frequently about the Great
War from the great wah to leave the
great world without me with various
characters coming back from the war
including Kenneth his younger brother
who happens to be a corpse lying in a
ditch and Jeremy Fisher one of his
finger puppets more on both of them a
little bit later salad also laments that
Kenneth must return to the trenches the
major fighting style of the First World
War
it's also worth remembering that in
between the two wars
no one called it World War one since no
one knew a second one was coming just a
few decades later as such while the u.s.
referred to it as the European war
during those years
Britain's preferred calling it the Great
War at least they did up until the 1940s
based on all of this evidence we know
that salad fingers is set in a version
of the UK in 1939 one still grappling
with the very real effects of the first
world war but right before the outbreak
of the second one who said a weird web
series about rubbing rust covered
objects with your grotesque leaf fingers
wouldn't be educational and here's where
it gets interesting because remember
based on horace horsecollar and the two
songs he sings the time we spend with
salad fingers is at least 1939 which is
20 years after the end of the great war
and yet he talks about it like it's
still going on he's delusional
mentally stuck in the past it's also
important to note that we see background
paintings of normal people in places
like the one in Episode one as well as
this one of a church in episode 5 from
flashbacks we can see that salad fingers
has experienced things like hair salons
so there is a real world here a real
world filled with actual normal-looking
people like the kid in episode 2 and his
picnic partner in episode 5
in short the post-apocalyptic wasteland
filled with irradiated mutants that
salad fingers wanders through is not
reality as many other theories believe
it's how he sees the world very clearly
there is a moment in his life during the
Great War that caused him to have a
break from the existing reality and he's
entered a state of Arrested Development
ever since which means that things start
to get complicated in a hurry because
not only is he lost in time but his
personality is also jumped while it
would be easy to lump all of salad
fingers actions onto one person he
actually shows himself to hop between
various characters and back stories
without realizing it
for instance when speaking with Kenneth
he laments being left behind as the rest
of the boys went out to the great war
last five
they routed you blokes to leave the
great wall without me but then two
episodes later we see him writing the
equivalent of a teacher's note
explaining why he can't come to the
front today implying that he's already
been there I shan't be able to attend
the war today
not to mention him speaking fluent
French Nabila comment a potato Kaska
leah in understanding Morse code both
skills a soldier would likely have from
his time during the war but made a
specially stranger since he shows that
he can neither read nor write as
evidenced by his failed letter writing
in Episode nine his made-up letter
reading earlier in that same episode and
his willful disregard for Harry the
barbeque man's nametag in episode two
instead choosing to name him male thank
you makeup and then joyfully play the
flute for him like I said this series is
so weird
we also clearly see him giving voice to
his own baby ah that's a shame you are
doing a first-rate job and repeatedly
slipping into the persona of a
flirtatious girl hitting on sailors back
for shore leave I'll be trouble maidens
clauses maybe can come and tuck me in
tonight sailors stop that's talking
about washing his petticoats out of cake
enough water in here to wash my
petticoat which is a girl's under skirt
just so you know not many of the beauty
gurus talking about their petticoats
these days it also repeatedly hopping
into dresses whether to sing on stage or
get himself married then in the final
episode he enters the forest hoping to
find a doctor to look at milford cubicle
who yes gesso happens to wind up as a
corpse hanging from the wall leave a
duty to fetch the doctor since i
wandering guests has fallen hell and
once the doctors found claims the
examination for himself
I suppose yelping checking me we also
see moments where salad fingers clearly
switches from one persona to the next
forgetting the name of one of his
favorite puppets Hubert cumbered ale and
having to make up a new one
if it isn't um the Barbara
Logan price forgetting that he intended
to give his baby away to anti Bainbridge
and deciding to clean the windows and
said Godard aunty Bainbridge has agreed
to take care of you I'm just here to
clean your windows and with the clear
change in attitude indicated by his
facial shift as the doctor brutalizes
the horse during the final scenes of
episode 10 I know it heads in short
solving the story of salad fingers isn't
just figuring out what's going on for
one character it's figuring out the
numerous people fingers gives voice to
decoding what they're saying and then
deciding how those actions all fit into
one overall narrative that's quite a
monumental task
so let's actually start with one of the
easiest of those characters which is his
younger brother Kenneth in episode 7
labeled shore leave the puppet Cubert
Humber Dale digs up a dead body whose
salad fingers identifies as his brother
back on leave from the Great War already
you can see how salad here is a little
bit of a tossed salad as he attributes
the digging of the hole to Hubert a
finger puppet rather than himself giving
us further evidence that he switches
between personalities lacking out what
happens in those moments from his own
memories now during his brothers visit
salad marvels at the women his brother
must have chased accounts details of his
own personal singing career and then
ends the visit by kicking Kenneth back
into the hole so he can return to the
trenches and resumed his Call of Duty
that's about as pleasant of a visit as
you can expect from a half desiccated
corpse except there's one flashback in
the middle of that visit that's awfully
suspicious salad fingers leads into the
flashback by telling a story of how he
and his brother used to shopping at the
myth aside we then here a typical
flashback transition and what we see
instead is our green friend rolling out
a measuring wheel and talking to a tree
yachts from the front birthday not quite
frolicking by the river with his brother
right well maybe it is what if his
brother is the tree or more accurately
what if his brother is buried under the
tree I propose to you that the younger
brother Kenneth never fought in the war
at all and instead died young perhaps
even in childbirth only to be buried
under this tree 21 yards away from salad
fingers front door and beyond just the
obvious flashback there are smaller
clues to this being the true story first
notice that the episode is labeled shore
leave and yet salad fingers says Kenneth
is headed back to the trenches as a
member of the US Royal Navy Kenneth
shouldn't be dealing with trenches as
his battles would be mostly fought at
sea so either it's a factual error here
or a fabricated memory by salad fingers
dreaming up his dead younger brother as
some sort of war hero getting all the
ladies but that's not all let's look at
the tree itself you see this wouldn't be
the only time that we see this tree
associated with babies during a dream
sequence at the top of episode 9 salad
fingers has a conversation with that
same tree which now sprouts a face and
complains about wanting to come inside
to escape the cold the difference though
is that this time the tree calls him
daddy
and when salad fingers refuses to help
mr. branches saying that the baby needs
to grow out of its branches to come
inside it wraps itself around its
stomach ending the dream and leading to
a scene where fingers actually gives
birth in fact when you look across all
10 of salad fingers episodes baby
imagery is everywhere from salad fingers
finding a baby carriage for his nettles
and starting to lactate in episode 3 to
him being attacked by the baby tree and
literally giving birth in episode 9 but
probably the clearest place that we see
it is in episode 4 cage where salad
fingers is literally followed around by
an embryo and that's no exaggeration
just look at this thing the large folded
over forehead the veins visible under
the skin it looks exactly like a baby in
the womb
even makes baby noises throughout the
episode but the giveaway here is in the
eye
salad fingers may be abstract in its art
style but it's not sloppy with its
imagery pay careful attention to the
eyes of the characters who appear
throughout the series the living
characters like salad fingers anti
Bainbridge varsity jacket Kidd and
Milford cubicle prior to his death all
have normal looking eyes the puppets all
have button leg eyes and this guy is the
only one to have misshapen black dots
just like the eyes of a developing
embryo I mean just compare the two
looking at embryo look at this character
they are one and the same but what does
it all mean well in cage we see salad
clearly disturbed by this thing
following him around he starts the
episode eager to find France because as
he says I've always wanted together but
once he realizes he's being chased by
the embryo he immediately puts off his
goal for another day returning home to
hide and it's not like this thing is
menacing with the contrary he's actually
incredibly friendly with hearts
appearing around it when it speaks to
salad fingers and proposing to him with
a ring sure it also lures him out of the
house with a grubby tap leading him to a
bear trap and locking him into that
titular cage but hey it was for love I
swear I did it all for love the episode
ends with salad disappearing flying away
on a tap once again wearing his beret
defined France while the embryo sits
there and cries it's a bizarre sequence
but also one that seems pretty literal
between this and the tree it's the
second time that we see salad fingers
actively walking away from babies
looking for affection in fact the
presence of the baby prevents salad
fingers from pursuing his dream of
finding France and literally traps him
which shows how salad psyche views
having kids it's a metaphor that
continues in episode 9 we're having baby
Yvonne starts as a happy moment but then
quickly turned sour as the baby doesn't
listen to him and instead slowly starts
to kill him to the point that the
enfeebled salad fingers has stuck in a
wheelchair and decides to give her away
time and time again throughout this
series we see salad fingers turning away
from children and running away from them
trapped by them and in some instances
outright killing them as is the case
with the boy that he accidentally
axe in the oven one of the few events in
the series that we can actually confirm
is a real occurrence since we see the
letter from his letterman jacket buried
in a pile of junk midway through the
final episode but what does it all mean
well at this point we've covered about
half the episodes meaning that there's
still quite a bit to go and the hardest
questions are yet to come including the
identities of his mysterious finger
puppets and the super dark imagery of
the final ending so I know you're gonna
hate me for it but I have to call this
one a two-parter so first make sure that
you're notified for part two rub your
salad mouse over this rusty subscribe
button so that you don't miss the upload
just so you guys don't get all upset at
me in the comments again let me just
clarify that I separate things out into
two parters for a bunch of reasons
mostly so I don't have to rush through
all the information as you can see
there's a lot to talk about in salad
fingers and I don't want to skip things
or cut a bunch out just to fit it in to
the typical 13 to 20 minute episode
length why not make it longer you ask
that's a legitimate question but there
are a few reasons first it already takes
around 80 hours to edit these videos
together so longer videos are just
brutal for Thomas Edward Ronnie and
sedge it's actually why I work with so
many editors because the episodes takes
so long to make we have to rotate
between everyone to make sure that the
episodes come out on a regular basis but
not only that I've seen the data on how
you guys watch these episodes once an
episode is over 17 minutes people tend
to cut out early so going far over 20
minutes is gonna mean that a lot of
people miss all the cool stuff that we
all worked really hard to show you guys
and lastly YouTube demands regular
videos and if you want to really grow
and stay relevant in today's YouTube you
really should be releasing stuff every
day now obviously we can't do that but
we do try our best to stay regular at a
theory a week that said if I take two
weeks off to work on one video YouTube
system will freak out and start
punishing the channel I hope that you
guys understand and I hope that you've
subscribed since I really want you to
see how this whole series wraps up this
thing is dark that's about it for this
week now if you'll excuse me I have to
go rub my finger on some rusty spoons it
feels so good on my salad fingers